il ya quelques temps j'avais fait une
vidéo sur les techniques de drague vous
expliquez que je galérais un peu avec
les meufs
mais bon ça c'était avant bon quand l
échange de textos pour la première fois
avec une meuf
c'est très bien si tu lui plaît ou pas
c'est ça ce voit juste avec les smileys
si elle fait un smiley coeur ces cas-là
fond sur toi si elle fait un smiley
bisous plus coeur d'encore un peu de ta
femme était sur la bonne voie
si elle fait un smiley bisous mais sans
coeur on sait pas ça pourrait très bien
être un bisou amical si elle fait les
doigts comme ça c'est plutôt mal parti
un latté bienvenue dans la fredzone et
si elle fait un immeuble comme ça bon
j'ai pas une explication pour tous les
smileys non plus c'est moi dès que je
suis en flirt avec une meuf
ouais j'emploie des mots des années 80
moi dès que je suis en flirt avec une
meuf et qu'on échange de textos je me
prends la tête pendant des heures pour
écrire un texto qui soit à la fois le
texto du mec intéressés mais quand même
un peu distant tels que j'écris juste
tout simple oui à de te voir point trop
sec
oui virgule hâte de te voir contrôle mec
dans la ponctuation
j'ai hâte de te voir bisous smiley ça
fait trois semaines dans la même phrase
à la brume qu'est ce qu'il a répondu
elle a mis un immeuble moi je sais pas
draguer je galère mais pourtant l
inverse les filles elle n'arrive
vraiment à me séduire avec un rien
excuse moi tu n'as pas du feu semblait
[Musique]
c'est hyper aguicheur je trouve de
cacher des trucs dans ses sous vêtements
d'ailleurs il ya que les filles qui
peuvent faire ça jamais un mec qui fait
[Musique]
tient il à saint paul g ouais non mais
je crois que j'ai plus envie de fumer en
fait c'est moi ça m'est déjà arrivé de
jouer un peu à la bagarre avec une fille
c'est ça rend complice assez mignon par
contre si tu te fais maîtrisé par la
meuf t'a tout de suite l'air un peu
moins attirants attend du baron du tout
là c'est trop mal dans ce genre de
circonstance moi je sors toujours cette
phrase non mais attends mais là je n'ai
pas toute ma force
normalement si je mettais toute ma force
à ce serait un truc de ouf sauf qu'au
bout d'un moment tu peux plus mentir
j'aurais peut-être mal à tous là je me
suis laissé faire par exemple c'est vrai
que pour draguer l'alcool c'est pas mal
c'est ça désinhibe tu te sois un peu
confiants moi j'aime bien sauf quand la
meuf est beaucoup plus bourré que moi
j'ai menti trop charmant trop embrasser
les capotes
je trouve ça traître parce qu'à la fois
il faut absolument en avoir sur soi
toujours par sécurité en même temps si
la mef se rend compte que tu en as
qu'une sur toi au tout début du rendez
vous alors que tu la peine de rencontrer
ça le fait pas trop
ah merde mais qu'est ce que ça fait là
c'est abusé tarek chami une capote dans
mon portefeuille
on peut l'acheter la poubelle je m'en
fous - au pire
j'avais dans ma poche dans le but de la
lâcheté plus tard ok c'est bon la jette
pas sur moi à chaque fois que dans ce
genre de situation on voit très bien si
je mens ou pas qui est
un préservatif un préservatif je sais
pas peut-être tu attends je vérifie j'en
ai 16 et un max de lubrifiants nickel un
jour je me suis inscrit sur un site de
rencontres pour déconner enfin pour et
quand tu t'inscris tu dois préciser ta
sexualité alors hétéros homos et alain
des choix qui était hétéro curieux je
trouve ça génial comme concept elle
aurait tué dangereux ah non moi je suis
juste et et aux curieux
je suis juste là par curiosité je prends
quelques notes
allez-y en vrai c'est un peu nul de
draguer c'est un peu nul de forcer les
choses ça y'a rien de plus agréable au
monde va que de séduire quelqu'un bat
sans faire exprès juste en étant
soi-même c'est en laissant son charme
naturel faire le travail
en tout cas je vais être sincère avec
vous depuis que tu es des vidéos je sais
pas pourquoi mais la question que tout
le monde me pose en particulier les
journalistes c'est toujours alors norman
avec le succès de vos vidéos
maintenant avec les filles ça se passe
comment 1 ça doit ça doit y aller quand
je dis ça doit y aller je parle pas
forcément de jouer aux échecs
si vous est ce que je veux dire un bon
sens qu'avec les filles maintenant c'est
disons un peu différent excuse moi je
t'ai vu tout seul au bar et jeanne voir
parce que c'est top
non c'est pas parce que tu es norman
fait des vidéos que tu peux venir pas
quel accord je suis pas une groupie
moi je veux juste rentrer en foulard je
crois que tu l'a fait tomber
non c'est trop mignon à temps c'est pas
parce que tu es norman fait des vidéos
que je vais dire merci aux quais [ __ ]
au revoir
[Musique]
chez oc mamie qui m'a envoyé une petite
carte avec un petit chaton trop mignons
ces adorables ya pas de chèque
y'a pas de chèque bages en bas les
couilles alors canaux suivants
[Musique]